visit expressvpn.com yang
and get three extra months of expressvpn
for free
the single biggest thing that america
has right now going against it
is that we have four or five companies
facebook apple amazon microsoft google
that
sucks up the enormity and the
overwhelming majority
of all talented technical human capital
because if you are a smart young kid
you know a guy or girl graduating from a
college and you know how to code or you
know how
you know how to do something unique how
do you
turn around to your family and say i'm
going to go
and work at this startup for 80 grand a
year or this non-profit or something
else
versus going and getting paid a million
dollars a year at one of these big
companies it's really impossible right i
mean i'm i don't know your situation but
when i graduated
that was the biggest sort of damocles
over my neck was the student debt that i
had
and so but when they go there what
products are they working on this is
unfettered free agentism imagine that
you had a professional sports league
where there was no salary cap
what would you do you would go and hire
and you would sign every single great
player stick them on the bench
you'd be guaranteed to win a
championship you'd be a monopolistic
championship winner year in year out
you're saying that they get paid to do
nothing because when you say the bench
that's what i thought of
yeah no no that's that's that is that is
the exact
explicit strategy
[Music]
zach we are back this week it's going to
be chamath palapatiya
who's a rock star uh
investor visionary entrepreneur
but before that we're going to talk
about maybe the greatest thing
i've ever been associated with which is
that we
helped get stimulus checks into this
relief bill
uh and as we're having this conversation
text is still getting finalized it looks
like it's going to be
six to seven hundred dollars for every
adult and child
but that adds up to something like 150
billion dollars that are gonna that's
gonna go out in the form of checks
uh right as people need it the most and
thank you to everyone who helped make
that happen
i'd love to uh walk through some of
how it happened with you for our
audience
it's so this is let's be clear on this
we both agree
600 to 700 per person
is not enough that we're we're bigger we
want more than that however it is way
better than zero
um so walk us through i'm beaming
right now because i've been particularly
the past
we've been working on this for a couple
of months but the pic particularly the
past couple weeks
we've really started to kick butt um and
the national media is never gonna give
you
the a lot of stuff behind the scenes
anyway but they're not gonna be like
andrew yang saved the day
but i actually believe you have saved
the day and this and humanity forward
actually has saved the day in
a in a healthy way so walk us through
what has happened from your end um and
and then where we how we got to where we
are right now
so if you remember in the run-up to the
election uh
nancy pelosi and mnuchin and until less
extent mcconnell just couldn't come to a
deal
uh and there was a moment when uh there
was a 1.8 trillion dollar offer
that had some problems but it was still
like uh to me like the best offer i'd
seen
um on the table and i went out
i went public and said hey we should
probably think about taking that deal
because that that's like
the best it's gonna get mitch mcconnell
hates it and right now they have
political interest in trying to get
something done
so that deal did not happen and
after the election uh humanity forward
pivoted very very hard
to lobbying for cash relief uh we we
become
a cash relief uh organization
that advocacy machine yeah advocacy
and you know what it reminds me of and
you and i joke about this act there was
a headline in the onion ten years ago
which was the american people hire a
lobbyist to represent
their interests on capitol hill and
there's like a picture of a lobbyist who
gets paid lots of money
and that headline stuck with me for 10
years because i thought that's a pretty
good idea
like maybe we should hire a lobbyist
just to hang out and be like hey you
know to help the people
stimulus checks for the record i think
the onion has some of the most
insightful
hilarious headlines like sometimes like
there's a reason they had a gesture back
in the day sometimes satire is the only
way to like cut to the core of the truth
so
kudos the onion yeah so we had this
pivot to talking to members of congress
and i've had over 65
zooms with different house members
senators
over the last number of weeks and i have
to say anytime
one of those meetings hits my schedule i
got so pumped
because i thought to myself that there
is at least some chance that this
conversation will lead to unlocking
tens hundreds of billions of dollars for
the american people
yeah so we've been working on it and
then
uh about two weeks ago still
no deal a group of bipartisan senators
stepped forward and said hey here's a
900 billion dollar compromise
bill that ended up getting all sorts of
momentum because there were
some republicans on it some democrats on
it and it looked like it could pass the
senate which has been the bottleneck
this whole time
and that did not include stimulus checks
uh the the 900 billion
was unemployment insurance love it
coronavirus costs
and resources love it obviously like
some for
vaccine distribution the disputed
elements
ended up being aid to city and states
which i completely
support and this liability shield
so this bipartisan gang of senators
could not agree
on those two elements and so they cut
the
900 billion dollar package by 160
billion or so with the
city and state government aid in a
separate
bill now simultaneously we were having
conversations with members of congress
uh and letting them know look all your
people love cash relief
uh economists love it um 74 percent of
americans are foreign including a
majority of both parties
and we got enough folks excited where
there was a bipartisan bill
led by representatives lisa blunt
rochester of delaware as a democrat
and david mckinley of west virginia
who's a republican so this bipartisan
cash relief bill
that percolated in the house a couple of
weeks ago and that was a result of
you know those 65 plus conversations
over a period of weeks
where we've been pinging various members
so then at the last mile
when they couldn't agree on this city
and state
government aid um then they ended up
swapping in
the stimulus checks of 600
or so for every adult and child which
costs
you know about that much money like
let's call it 160 billion dollars
uh so when i got the call saying that
stimulus checks are in uh because of us
like i i jumped for joy i ran around
uh and like grabbed evelyn was like i
think this is like the greatest thing
i've ever done
because you think about the tens of
millions of americans who are struggling
right now
getting six hundred dollars a person
like let's say that you have you know
two folks in your household
um that would qualify could be like a
single mom and a child i mean twelve
hundred dollars in january is going to
be a game changer
couldn't agree more that like in my mind
we should be doing doing something
much more dramatic ongoing for everyone
uh but realistically this bill when it
first hit
the the uh senate floor
didn't have any stimulus checks in it
you know like
and so the fact that i went from not
having stimulus text to stimulus checks
is a major major win and thank you to
the team at humanity ford thank you to
everyone who's donated
uh to our efforts because this return we
did the math it's something like
a million x return on uh what we've
uh spent on direct lobbying and we've
spent much more in a lot of other things
we've given 10 million
away to folks or so um but we haven't
spent that much money on lobbying it's
been a lot of my time
um you know and my time costs uh nothing
in our calculations so
it was like and
but it really it's it's everyone who
helped elevate this movement to a point
where members of congress
and senators are happy to take a meeting
with me you know like like that that's
actually in in many ways the
accomplishment of the last couple of
years
where we elevated our movement to a
point where folks will meet with me
because they'll know look yang's got a
lot of fans he's got
you know a million person mailing list
like social media following in a million
so thank you
we freaking did it we helped get real
relief to the american people
and again uh the highest point of my
career thus far
it makes me so proud i'm so excited to
be part of it and i think there's a
couple things
one just for just make sure everybody
knows we think it's fundamentally
fundamentally ridiculous that it took
this long and this much work to make
this happen it seems like a no-brainer
to
help your people in the pandemic if
you're a canadian you've received
tons of money um for until the economy
doesn't crash
so your society doesn't crumble um so
we're we're behind
the curve as a nation and it's it's
really frustrating but i will say this
when we ran andrew we were frustrated
when we met the leadership
um and the people in charge um in some
ways because we didn't think they were
in touch with a lot of the people we
were talking to you know
um and our conclusion and
my conclusion particularly was that the
cavalry wasn't wasn't coming to save us
uh there was no cavalry and we were it
and
this effort and frankly
quick success like we haven't been doing
this that long
um for us to have as much influence as
we did on getting this through
shows to me that we have to be the
cavalry doing something
um was uh one better than nothing but
two so so powerful because no one's
doing anything
like we were going to senators and
congressmen and women and saying hey
your constituents are hurting they need
cash
everybody supports it and what was their
reaction andrew i didn't even know that
that makes sense to me thank you for
telling me that i'll fight well
what they didn't see was the the numbers
like
all of them expressed like wow 74
approval rating like that that's as high
as it gets
you know and there's no reason they
would have known that necessarily
yeah without us providing it it's been a
real education
um so there are two things i mean put
very simply like we're in a
deep dark hole our government should be
helping to dig us out
i think it is ridiculous that people are
hemming and hawing about
the cost of water when the house is on
fire it's like just get the hoses out
and start going to work
um and so it should be in the trillions
of dollars but there are two things we
can influence in my mind
number one is what's the size of the
overall relief
the higher the better in my view which
like i multiple trillions
yes we should do that especially the
second thing is
yeah the second thing is the composition
of the aid it's like
if you have a higher proportion go
directly to people and families that's a
win
uh if you have uh a lower proportion go
to megacorps that are just gonna like
stick it on their balance sheet and
chill with it and probably
you know frankly furlough people anyway
like walt disney did
like that that's a loss so
uh so so those are the two things i'm
trying to influence is like
more is better more to people is better
uh and
on this one there was even a chance i
would we were told that like
you know there might have been um
less on the table like that like there's
no guarantee so when they had this
disputed hundred
uh 60 billion or so
in city and state aid there was no
guarantee that was going to get replaced
like because what they did is they
separated the legislation into the part
that everyone would agree on and they
separated that part
so the fact that stimulus checks got in
there like grew that
relief package by 160 billion or so
and it went directly to people so those
are the the goals we're chasing
and if anyone listening to this thinks
like wow like you know
you want to be a part of this please do
uh follow humanity forward
become a recurring donator to humanity
forward think of it as like the best
investment you'd ever make
um because this stuff works like you
know i was joking but it's like
lobbying [ __ ] works no wonder
companies do it
it's like it works yeah like you know we
we like uh just got in there and
it worked yeah
it like blew my mind like completely
dude we spent you know
what we spent like nine million dollars
giving money to people and families and
that was awesome
right but we spent 120 000 let's say
giving it to some lobbying firms that we
like and trusted and to go fight for
people and now we're getting
billions to go to people yeah you know
it does make one think about the ratio
[Laughter]
and to be clear this is like a magical
moment we were in the right place the
right time we had some great legislators
like lisa blunt roger yesterday
mckinley and bernie came out and
supported it right yeah like like a
a bunch of other folks um so a lot of
things had to converge at the same time
but i can genuinely say
uh i believe that we were integral to
this happening
uh you know like if we have not been
working it then there
was a real chance that this does not
happen
and i couldn't be happier and prouder
it's like this
it is wild it's like this is the
pinnacle of
uh impact on human life that that i i've
uh
i can actually point to um you know
topping this is going to be
uh difficult but we should definitely
keep trying because you know like the
crisis is going to rage on um there are
going to be more relief bills coming out
of congress
in the new year for sure because the
city and state government piece
is still there uh democrats are going to
fight for it rightfully by the way in my
view
um so they're going to be more relief
packages and we have to keep on trying
to improve them
yeah you called me yesterday and you
said
zach this is the greatest thing i've
ever done and not from uh like i did
this because a lot of people did this
but more on like uh
as a you know you look at your career
and you try to reflect on yourself and
what
impact you had in the world and said
look we can
we could hang it up right now and feel
proud about
the level of dent we've put in um into
other
positive dent we've put in other
people's lives you know and we're not
going to part of it too zack it
is that now you had two relief packages
and two stimulus checks like now
it's going to be like hey can't be a
relief package that's stimulus checks i
mean that
like that also this really does set like
a very very firm
uh precedent um and the stimulus checks
are the most
popular things we're doing one of our
early digital guys andrew frawley in the
campaign
said um he was with us from day one um
and he was saying that um he's asking if
we had survivorship bias from the
campaign in the sense that when you
survive a car crash something crazy and
like with no
odds just to live through it um you
believe you're invincible
and we keep having these massive
successes that are like completely
improbable
um and there's this one hand that's like
that's cause we're invincible or
we can do anything and that's not true i
but i mean it feels somewhat like
like everything we're touching is is
having success and it's because i think
we've tapped into a movement you know
you are powered this movement is power
this podcast is powered by
amazing people who all see what's
happening
and you are the vessel for them and
frankly in my opinion and
i believe it's a fact fiercely loyal to
them um
like you will you'll make tough
decisions but you are fighting for
them i know that because i live it cause
i'm like we should do this you're like
people don't want that we got to you
know i'd say that a lot with you
um but i it's just fun to watch
kind of the outrageous um wins we've
been able to have even though in
franklin he's in these dark times you
know so that does excite me and
hopefully excites you too andrew
this is still a very early stage for
this movement that we're building
it's it's funny because i ran for
president
uh and you know we had a measure of
success
uh and there was part of me that was
like well you know we have to transfer
the energy very quickly into like an
ongoing
uh organization and movement um in the
form of humanity forward
um and um i did not expect us to have
this kind of impact as quickly
really um so that that's a thrill of
course that you know
we're in the midst of an historic
catastrophe
and our government should be doing much
much more so i think we're plugging into
now as you said just what people see is
it's the right thing
you know like the cases we're making and
that's one of the things that really
surprised me about the institutional
nature of it all
is is that like when i said hey nancy
pelosi should probably take that deal
uh or a version of it uh and then people
like attacked me for it and so it was
like
who are you to like you know question
this person's
uh judgment i was really really shocked
that there were so few people that
razer hannah were like hey people need
help winner's coming
like this is a lot of money like that
let's do this thing
uh it was uh you know it was crickets
for the most part i mean
it was very odd uh and and the fact that
people were
you know uh attacking me for it i was
like use your judgment
sometimes offers get worse not better
like the amount of political leverage
you have right now is as high as it's
ever going to be
like why would you think that it's going
to go up from 1.8 trillion not down
you know it's like like you know and so
like that there's this real
institutionalization this is why our
movement has so much power zach
is that there are a number of people who
actually see it and then
evaluate and be like okay you know that
makes sense to me
um and we have institutions that are
putting forward a lot of things that
only make sense if you're embedded in
like whatever weird landscape it is like
like stimulus checks for people make
common sense to everyone in the country
you know three quarters of americans are
for it
the only place where it makes less sense
is as soon as you get to capitol hill
then all of a sudden it's like oh you
know like we
we should really be like looking at
other things uh you know or
the media narratives it's like you can
see something happening
um and only in the media would that make
sense
like like in many ways
like we're like the lair of people um
who are uh like calling out stuff that
we can all
see and fight for um and
my campaign was about you know people
versus the machines and people thought
of that as like robots ai which
kind of was technology though i don't
hate that stuff i mean i'm kind of
into it um but but it's really it's
another
set of machines really it's like this
institutional machinery
um where [ __ ] that makes no sense makes
sense
and vice versa what i really hope is
like look i think there's a lot of
people that
we love the savior complex where we put
your hope in trump you put your hope in
bernie you put your hope in
by then you put your hope in andrew yang
right the person
and i understand that i felt that in
some ways i feel that about josh allen
on the buffalo pills um
or things like that but the reality is
what really saves you is
um and will save us is is more than
andrew it's
it's the rationality and common sense
we're trying
it's the ideas and logic behind what
will actually help us
um and you're not gonna be perfect i'm
not gonna be perfect right like that
you'll never be everything to everybody
but
you can rationally try to solve a lot of
these problems that are messy and
complicated and put
some a sane human being in charge of a
lot of these things like that's what i
hope we can convey like love or hate
you me the movement
we the intentionality and logic behind
the solutions we're
presenting should help a lot of people
um
and cut through the noise because
there's such a lack of that
in politics you agree with that oh well
i certainly agree that
with the fact that you know hanging
everyone's hopes on like singular
um leaders is not optimal for a movement
uh you know uh i um and the movement
will coalesce around new leaders in
different
uh ways like trumpism is going to
outlive trump you know
no matter what um and that there's a
massive appetite for
the principles we stand for um that is
manifesting in different ways i agree
with those things
certainly also agree with my own fall
ability and uh and definitely your fall
ability
i feel like in the bar here like i'm
just trying to keep up man
kidding kidding um i mean you know it's
like but we're
we're only human and like it it's like i
will say i don't feel that much
um you know artifice i mean i feel like
most people know
what you and i are about um and you know
when we screw up they'll be like yeah
yeah
that that makes sense we're trying but
but the cash relief portion really
everyone who has touched this movement
everyone who supported my presidential
campaign you should really
hold your head up high today because
everything we did
to try and mainstream these ideas uh
and make it so that we could influence
policy
paid off for tens of millions of
americans for real
uh this winter um i could not be prouder
i could not be happier
i hope you're proud and happy to and i
hope this reinforces the importance of
what we've done
um and i continue to do like i i
actually feel
more energized and invigorated
and frankly able to influence real life
things than i did
certainly um the day we suspended my
presidential campaign
and that's a a wonderful feeling because
you know you run for president
you don't win uh like what next
and i i'm 100 certain that we have grown
in influence and reach and impact
leaps and bounds since then i am so
freaking proud of that so thank you yang
gang thank you zach
thank you to the team at humanity
forward um
so proud of you all uh you know we just
got to keep going
uh but this is this is something we
should relish and celebrate
amen with that let's go to our guests
man i don't think we get better than
that what an episode what a
what a moment for us we got a lot of
work to do i'm a big believer in
celebrating the wins you know and this
was
looks like a win you know such a win
high point of my professional life so
coming up next
uh fascinating conversation with world
class
investor visionary futurist
chamath palapatiya he's become famous
more recently because he was on cnbc
and then folks were asking him what to
do about uh these companies
and industries and he was like who cares
about the companies and industries we
have like systems for that you know they
have to go through like a
recap or a reorg or bankruptcy it's fine
just take care of the people
you know just like send the money to the
folks who work at those companies and
then like you know
like our corporate systems have
processes and then people are like but
what about the investors and he's like
who cares like
you know like we're like well we'll be
fine like why are you trying to
recap these companies and like preserve
the the investors instead of the people
that work with them so that
cnbc clip went went viral um
and uh you know got him a lot of um
praise rightfully so because it really
like that that was a dose of common
sense
and the fact that he said it on cnbc
everyone was so like shocked and
appalled
it was uh um so coming up next
my convo with chamath palapatiya
[Music]
[Applause]
the yang gang is a very creative bunch
we love to learn
we love to interface with folks who are
a little bit ahead of us on the curve
in a particular skill and one way to get
everything you need
from a creative class or community is
skillshare skillshare
is the world's leading community of
folks who want to
get better and learn from experts it's
an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning
like that does that not sound like us it
sounds like us to me
it's also incredibly affordable because
that's also very us we try and keep
things affordable around here
so i i last time i talked about this i
talked about this iphone photography
class i took and now i'm doing
diy do-it-yourself product photography
um
not that i want to be a photographer i
just find it uh
helpful because we take a lot more
photos and you realize and my photos
always suck they always suck i take a
photo of the family
it's all shadowy everybody looks you
look funny you got three chins whatever
it is so you try to um i've been
learning some cool tips and tricks on
how to be a better photographer just for
like everyday life which i find helpful
um so if you are interested in
learning more and taking these types of
either creative or thoughtful or
marketing classes skillshare.com is
pretty awesome you just go to
skillshare.com
yankspeaks and get free trap so it's a
free child premium membership
that's one of a kind it can be
personalized and perfectly imperfect
learn a whole bunch of things about what
you put your time
and your effort and it's a great gift
around the holidays to show how much you
care about someone who's looking for
self-improvement and stuff to do during
quarantine so
skillshare.com yankspeaks get your free
trial check it out
it's pretty awesome
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome the yang
speaks i've been looking forward to this
conversation for months
months jamaat palapatiya
how are you andrew what's going on man
now how do how do we introduce this man
it's like one of the most
uh innovative investors in the universe
uh but more than that he's like an
iconic class a speaker of truth
someone who goes and like shakes the
trees i you first hit
i feel like at least my consciousness
and the consciousness of a lot of folks
and i know
this was and it was kind of fraught is
when you expressed your reservations
about
everything that went down with uh
facebook and you were like man i'm not
sure if we
if we were like the pure good we we kind
of hope to be
um but you've done so much since then
yeah it was um that was 2016 and that
was the first time i think people
outside of tech knew who i was people
inside of tech have known me for a while
but
um and then and then i guess it was just
this february or march during the middle
of the or the beginning of the pandemic
where there was another sound bite that
kind of got broadly distributed and
here i am was lucky to you i made it you
made it
so was the sound bite at the beginning
of the
shutdown when you were like hey like who
cares about
um the corporate uh structure or the cap
table of like the airlines or other
companies want to just like bail out the
people
we have systems to handle what goes on
with the company's balance sheet uh
is that the sound bite you're talking
about yeah exactly i was just i was
completely shocked that you know you
would reward these
you know basically idiotic ceos and
boards with
hundreds of billions of dollars when
average everyday normal people were
completely getting turned upside down
it made no sense yes it did not make any
sense
uh and thank you for speaking up there
were a lot of folks that did pass that
clip
uh to me and the yang gang and everyone
was like judge about speaking sense like
it's like you're one of the only people
who would go on some place like cnbc and
talk sense
well i think i i mean at some point you
know look you're if you're fed by the
system which those guys are you have to
basically
trumpet conventional wisdom and if you
have a little you know if you can be
emancipated you can kind of tell the
truth most
people want to tell the truth they uh
but i just think they find it hard and
uh
uh fortunately for better or worse i can
tell the truth
yeah you are one of the biggest
truth-tellers
um in the investment world for sure in
the tech world yeah maybe in american
life at this point
so when evelyn and i saw your 2016 sound
bite that went viral
my wife evelyn was like we have to find
out more about him
and so then we looked up your bio and
saw that you know you grew up the
child of immigrants in in canada not in
affluent circumstances
kind of went through a lot and then you
wound up
um finding your way first to finance and
then to tech and then became part of
like these various rocket ships but
there was like a humility to you and
your background where it's like despite
all of your success it felt like
you hadn't let like the the [ __ ]
creep too much into your like
in your mind was like was the sense that
both emilyn and i got
you know the the the most important of
the 10 crack commandments from the
drurious big is
never get high on your own supply um and
so i've tried to
i've tried to live that out like the
reality is that um
i had a lot of skills that my parents
gave me
but they also burdened me with some
enormous insecurities and
it kind of kept me checked so i think in
balance
um you know i never got too ahead of
myself i was kind of always trying to
fight to figure out who i was
and that that helped a lot to be honest
well i i too grew up the son of
immigrants but you know in my case my
dad was a
physicist and engineer so i you know as
a circumstance where my brother and i
were kind of expected to
get good grades and the rest of it uh
which was like a different
backdrop um the part of your background
that i find
like you know most fascinating i want to
dig into is so you had a lot of business
success
and then you started a firm called
social capital and social capital did
stuff that
was like a dream um because you probably
know from my presidential campaign
uh i'm a capitalist i think capitalism
uh
is a very positive force in you know
human life
um but i also think that there are these
massive problems that capitalism
isn't really directed at in earnest like
if you have certain
types of problems that a market driven
company can address then
venture capitalists will throw money at
them uh and the the thing
that fascinated me about you in social
capital is you're trying to
apply those resources to problems that
were longer term that were bigger they
were more social
um you know i think you were one of the
only investors that was really pursuing
health care and education
and i used to joke that health care was
where good ideas go to die
um because i worked in health care tech
for four years a lot of people don't
know this about me but like the early
2000s i worked at a
company that tried to manage patient
pre-surgical data
digitally and it was such a freaking
disaster like you go in there and these
hospitals
like you're like oh my whiz-bang product
it should work
and so i feel like because of the
regulatory backdrop and a bunch of other
things
like some investors shied away from it
um so i love the fact that you actually
tried to take
the mechanics of venture capital to the
biggest human problems
when um when i was when i left facebook
i left because i was working on a
project i was a you know pretty
technical person a product an
engineering person and
you know my team was responsible for
building up facebook to hundreds of
millions and then billions of users and
um
uh along the way i was building a phone
and to compete against android and apple
and when push come to shove mark and i
just couldn't get aligned on
you know me getting the amount of money
that i wanted and so i left
and um i remember i was sort of on my
way to take a vacation
right before i started social capital
and i got on the phone with peter thiel
and i said peter do you want to invest
with me and you know i had made peter a
lot of money at facebook and so he said
absolutely how much you're going to
invest
in yourself and what's crazy was up
until that point nobody had asked me
that
and i said i don't know you know like 5
10 15 20 million bucks he goes not
enough
he's like you need to be at least 30 of
the money and at the time it was like a
300 million dollar fund or something
and so i did it and the most important
thing andrew that i got
from that was control and i didn't
realize how important control would
become
because when i chose to invest in some
of these areas and push came to shove
there was a lot of investor capitulation
because these folks are paid to
basically get money back into their
institutions and endowments and family
offices that they work on behalf of
and this is when i really started to see
the problem which is that you have these
enormous parts of society that are
broken where
free markets and capitalism could fix
them
yeah but then the money comes from
essentially rich people
and the problem is helping rich people
stay rich
is a a pretty sad
use of one's time quite honestly at the
end of the day and b
their appetite to take risk is de
minimis because they
like staying rich and so you start to
have
all of these systemic market failures
and this is a lot of why people point to
capitalism as perverted
or not working but it's because we have
we have moved away from what it's
supposed to do
it's supposed to allow humans to make
money by serving other humans serving
and that's the whole point and instead
we've refactored it
into humans market manipulating and
you know trading in esoteric instruments
or you know gerrymandering the financial
markets
um and all of that is just so utterly
wasteful and sad
um and so you know social capital
started initially with myself and
a bunch of other folks is money and then
it migrated to largely just being my own
so that i could take on the task in a
small way of working in these market
failures and trying to fix them
without having return pressure and then
as it turns out
you end up making more money anyways and
so
i think we've struck on a formula i
think it's one that's
kind of like pretty bold and hopeful um
and
now the goal is to just do it at a scale
that's hopefully one or two orders of
magnitude bigger than
the way in which we're doing it now well
i would love to
dig in to what you found works in that
space
but i also completely agree that there
are a lot of financial actors
who their job is just to generate a
certain return on investment in a
certain time period
and it's really influenced the way
companies get built where you show up
i i have friends who took big slugs of
vc
money and then the pressures on them to
grow to the moon just skyrocketed
no i mean i've said this before but to
your point um
the federal reserve has sort of
unfortunately been derelict in their
duty
they now work in this weird contorted
way with
treasury to print and introduce enormous
amounts of money into the system
what that's done is financialized every
part of our economy
and the problem is there are certain
things that should never have been
financialized
flying a rocket should not be
financialized right finding a cure to
cancer
should not be financialized figuring out
some great compelling leap in
ai and machine learning should not be
financialized
but we have and so what that means are
venture capitalists no longer are
technologists they are
financial arbitragers private equity
folks aren't business builders they are
expense managers on and on down the line
you know hedge fund folks aren't market
strategists they are market timers
you put all of that together and
basically what happens is the economy
whipsaws based on the whims of a few
folks a few rich folks who have the
ability to
you know swing large amounts of money
and then again these things that should
be fixed through technology and
innovation don't get fixed
um and so this is this is sort of like
the the problem at hand when
when you hear young people screaming
from the mountaintops that capitalism is
dead
i think what they're really saying is we
have not seen
nor do we see enough of examples of
people that are solving these things in
a way that they're proud of
and that's because too many people spend
their time shuffling paper and just
moving money around
to the young people who think that
capitalism
is not working they're right based upon
the last number of years and decades
because
at this point you have the winner take
all economy that's kind of compounding
on itself
and then there are a lot of folks who
can make a lot of money not solving
really the biggest problems that are
growing more serious all the time
especially now with the coronavirus
and that's why i really can't wait to
hear what you found
[Music]
do you know what time it is yang speaks
listeners it's time
to learn about expressvpn
they are the best they are the virtual
private network
rated number one by cnet and wired
don't let your data be hanging out in
the
internet for someone to grab and resell
over and over again don't do it don't do
it instead
get expressvpn you beam into the
internet through their secure servers
and it's like your secret agent no one
can find you
your data can't be sold resold that's
expressvpn for you
so if this sounds good to you i mean the
song sounded terrible i apologize
but if the ideas behind the song sounded
good to you
visit expressvpn.com yang that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang to get three months free off of the
top-rated virtual private network
by cnet and wired you can beam into the
internet
uh and no one will be the wiser your
data will
stay yours expressvpn.com right now to
learn more
you sound like buddy from elf like will
ferrell and elf when he's singing to his
dad
um he's just making up a song as he goes
which is pretty awesome or like those
improv groups and they try and sing
together the same tune and they don't
know the melody uh which is hilarious
however
um i'll say this like um ask yourself
like how are you choosing which internet
service provider you use and the sad
thing is most of us
don't have we have very little choice if
you will because these isps operate like
monopolies in the regions that they
serve and then they use that monopoly
power to take advantage of their
customers so data caps and streaming
throttles and
the list goes on and frankly the more
android and i've learned about this the
worse we
feel um and worst of all they log your
internet activity
and they sell that data to other big
tech companies and advertisers
uh which is not right and not fair we're
very very against it and to prevent
that um frankly from seeing my internet
activity we protect
all of our devices with expressvpn so
check it out expressvpn.com
yang and if you go maybe yang will stop
singing
probably not though so uh expressvpn
never
slashing
[Applause]
so i get that you say look guys we're
going to tackle real problems like
healthcare and education
that are thorny and human and difficult
and might not have the the same kind of
trajectory as like the
um the business or consumer facing tech
that we're used to
and then i get that your investors are
like wait a minute i didn't sign on for
this stuff
necessarily like you know come on uh
jamal you could like
pick all these winners in like easier
spaces and then eventually you're like
hey guys like
that's not really what i'm about um so
i'm curious how many other folks
have the same mindset you do where it's
like look i made a lot of money
i want to handle i want to tackle really
important problems
that aren't as market friendly or time
frame friendly
um as the stuff we customarily invest in
um there's a handful of folks
um i think that um the the the sort of
the
the grandfather of the space the person
who's really pioneered this path is a
guy by the name of vinod khosla um yeah
he's a he's an incredible entrepreneur
and his firm coastal ventures i think
has done
um huge amounts to help the world in
climate change and sustainability and
agriculture
he's an example i think that there are
other organizations actually now that
are more
institutional that focus on innovation
lux capital as an example based in new
york
so there are some but by and large the
incentives aren't to do that the
incentives are that you can get
paid a lot of money to just basically
you know put money into things that are
obvious
mark up those companies raise another
fund and
rinse and repeat because that pays you a
great yearly
compensation and at that point you know
that's
you you kind of have to ask yourself why
would i even bother trying to solve
cancer
you know like this is crazy it's just
going to take too long too much money i
may look stupid i may get fired
and so um you know people's own
simplified incentives kick in
um and innovation stops yeah it's much
easier to try and
jam yourself into airbnb or uh pre-ipo
or something and then like turn around
and be like hey
like i'm a genius investor i had my
annual meeting today
and what was so funny is i remember um
this is for my historic venture funds
you know and look i
put a billion three or four into the
ground and
you know i told these guys look guys
you're going to make somewhere between
five and six billion dollars
so congratulations it's all great and
one of my
ex partners texted me and he said you
know these are the same guys who just
got so agitated when you did a 3d
you know rocket printing company which
is now the second most valuable space
business after uh spacex that's private
you know where we did this uh satellite
business that's also a multi-billion
dollar business where we did
uh an ai chip company that's helping to
you know do a lot of interesting things
in science
um you were just not rewarded and again
i go back to this peter thiel discussion
if peter hadn't forced me
or hadn't put peer pressure on me to put
so much money in i would have never made
those investments
now the way that i think about it is
look you know
i have a pretty
like crazy track record and just kind of
making
money which is kind of okay um it's
nothing that i'm particularly proud of
but i want to use it and so the way i
think about it is
you know we have an organization where
if you put money in a ton of money comes
out
we've done it for 10 years it's and it's
like 35
to a year return so when you put you
know five or 10 billion dollars into a
system like that every year you're
spitting out two or three or four
billion of cash
but then i can take that andrew and i
can pump it into climate change and i
can pump it into education and
you know because it's all of our own
capital all of my own capital
i don't have to answer to anybody except
the employees and the founders and the
market
right and so you know for example there
was a really incredible innovation that
came out a few weeks ago from google
called
alpha fold now what is that they're
using machines
to guess the structure of proteins and
you may think well what does that have
to do with me well as it turns out
that is the basic building block to
eradicate and solve an enormous swath of
diseases
and so we have reduced an incredible
problem of human
health to one of compute power and to
one of distribution
now that's where i could easily pour a
billion dollars of capital
spend the next 10 years and say guys
let's take you know crawl walk run an
approach and let's just have
20 or 30 really important diseases that
we can you know
basically put out a business um and i
don't have to answer to anybody except
the scientists that work on the projects
and then the market and the people
suffering from those diseases will say
chemoth
faster or hey it doesn't work or hey it
looks like it's working
um and so i find myself for the first
time
very happy actually like you know
reasonably content because
we have this you know it's kind of like
being a country andrew i think in like
you know like you're saudi arabia
and one day you wake up and it's like
there's oil underneath your feet
and all you have to do is just suck it
out and then when you sell it in the
market you have money except in our case
we have a plan with what to do with the
money
you know we we have these areas that we
just think need to get fixed
for humanity just to thrive that's
incredible that
you've gotten that kind of uh visibility
into some of the thorniest problems and
you feel like you can make headway and
solving them i spent a number of years
running a non-profit
that was trying to help young
entrepreneurs in different markets
around the country
uh primarily in the midwest and the
south i would interact with billionaires
and then i would say hey support my
nonprofit or support this thing i'm
doing
and if they were into it they would make
a move
but even if you are a billionaire you
don't move in increments of like
you know 25 30 million like if they were
wanted to be really supportive of my
organization i might get one or two
million
um and then i would be you know frankly
i have to be like well that's freaking
awesome because you know two million
dollars it's like nothing to sneeze at
um but but there was this sense i had
that among these billionaires i knew
like they were looking at trying to
solve particular problems
and they didn't think they had the
resources and you're like wow i'm like
with a billionaire and like they don't
think they have it
um so i'm curious what your mindset has
been when you look at some of like the
biggest
problems humanity is facing uh and
the scope of the problem relative to the
resources that are being applied to
solve that problem
i i really haven't met a problem that is
really
one of capital um and i think that i
have more than enough resources to solve
all the problems that we're trying to
solve except one critical one
which is human capital and i think
that's the that's the most important
thing to take away which is that
it's not that for example like let's
just say that you and i
said hey let's go and get every single
home in america to be carbon neutral
okay that's at a great goal right how
would we do it well i can tell you i can
tell you what the answer is and the
answer is actually not
too complicated which is every house has
a roof
every roof can support residential solar
all of that solar energy can get
basically stored on site in an extremely
safe
and predictable battery and then you can
give
the homeowner or the apartment dweller
an app
that allows you to know exactly how much
energy those solar cells on the roof
has has generated and then you can use
it to power the home or the apartment
and whatever is less you can put back
into the grid so
how do you solve it as it turns out it's
not one of capital because you can get
hundreds of billions of dollars of
project finance to do that
because people spend hundreds of
billions of dollars buying the bonds of
utilities every single day in the
marketplace the really complicated part
is
can you get 15 or 20 engineers to build
the right
app that allows you to basically
understand how energy is managed and
recirculated
can you get the right you know battery
scientists and chemists to build the
right battery storage
technology can you string those
batteries together across a neighborhood
so what i've found and i could be
totally wrong but
what i found is that most of these
solutions are ones of
human capital and that it doesn't take
tens or hundreds of billions of dollars
people find ways of spending that much
money
but that's just a lot of um poor
planning now
if eventually andrew you and i were to
find a solution
what i would say is it probably would
cost 50 million to figure out
then you and i would say let's go to a
small town like palo alto or
you know some place and say let's deploy
that there and figure it out
and then let's go to a city like austin
or miami and say hey guys here's what we
found
let's go roll it out through all of
miami and then we would go nationwide
and along the way
the capital markets are actually very
liquid and would give you all that money
non-dilutively
so it's not that i intend to never work
with the capital markets i just think
that
in that early phase the single hardest
thing to find is actually the people
um and at the end of the day these
solutions can be found for hundreds of
millions of dollars
this is why i always sort of get trapped
in
you know people people have approached
me constantly and it's like
hey what's your philanthropic strategy
or charitable strategy and i
and i say to be honest with you i think
that
all of these problems that i'm looking
at will be solved
with technology-oriented solutions the
ones that i am the most
um sympathetic to climate change
sustainability agriculture health
education um and so you know eventually
will i you know find a way to give all
the money away sure
but right now you know i think it's
important to recycle it back into
for-profit businesses because
this is how i solve the human capital
problem the single biggest thing that
america has right now
going against it is that we have four or
five companies
facebook apple amazon microsoft google
that sucks up
the enormity and the overwhelming
majority of
all talented technical human capital
because if you are a smart young kid
you know a guy or girl graduating from a
college and you know how to code or you
know how
you know how to do something unique how
do you
turn around to your family and say i'm
going to go
and work at this startup for 80 grand a
year or this non-profit or something
else
versus going and getting paid a million
dollars a year at one of these big
companies it's really impossible right
i mean i'm i don't know your situation
but when i graduated
that was the biggest sort of damocles
over my neck was the student debt that i
had
and so but when they go there what
products are they working on this is
unfettered free agentism imagine that
you had a professional sports league
where there was no salary cap
what would you do you would go and hire
and you would sign every single great
player stick them on the bench
you'd be guaranteed to win a
championship you'd be a monopolistic
championship winner here in europe
you're saying that they get paid to do
nothing because when you say the bench
that's what i thought of
yeah no no that's that's that's that is
that is the exact
explicit strategy absolutely so
so this is why i think again we have to
find market-driven solutions
we have to find a way to use technology
to build successful for-profit companies
because we have to convince all these
people that are frankly withering and
dying on the vine at these companies
that they should be working at these
young dynamic businesses
you know this is the forward bleeding
edge like if you think about what
happened in 1969
right the apollo project was the
pinnacle of innovation in america
but what did you really have in that
moment what you had was an extremely
diverse ecosystem
where you had a public private
partnership you had the government that
was basically
an enormous balance sheet plus a lot of
regulatory
freedom and the ability to explore which
then saw the germination of hundreds of
companies and an ecosystem
trying to get america into space and
meant to the moon and then back now we
have the exact opposite
we have the federal government that
isn't exactly sure what its posture
should be
they work with an incredibly dated set
of laws from antitrust to otherwise
section 230 and otherwise and then we
have a handful of companies
that are effectively monopolies that
understand that their balance
sheet is a tool that their balance sheet
is equivalent
to most other governments in the world
except maybe the united states
right if you if you put the gdp of
countries on a
list and then put the market cap of
these big companies together
these five companies are probably top 50
countries
sure right and so and so yeah you can
green mail people
you can basically work on all kinds of
non-some you know nonsense and random
stuff and
as a result innovation slows down
um progress slows down
as a result wage growth slows down as a
result
people's frustrations grow and then they
point to capitalism
except really again what it is is a
bunch of financialization on one side
and green mail and hostage taking on the
other that have basically trapped a
whole cohort of young people and working
on the things that really matter
jamaat i spent a number of years trying
to counteract this i don't know how much
you know about my work with venture for
america
so what what uh we did was we recruited
enterprising young people some of them
technical some of them not
to work at early stage growth companies
in detroit new orleans baltimore
cleveland
birmingham and another half dozen
cities around the country that are not
new york san francisco
with the thought process being exactly
what you described which is look right
now if you're
a whiz kid out of a lot of places
banks and consulting firms and tech
companies will wave money at you
and then you will go there and you will
do something that's not super
socially productive and so wouldn't you
rather
start a business in a place or help a
business grow in a place that
uh could use the talent could use the
energy could use the help i spent
six and a half years running a
non-profit that did this and has done
this
for at this point hundreds maybe
thousands of young people and i saw
the market forces you're describing in
action where
if you're a really bright kid out of pen
and you go to a startup in new orleans
then you see your friends getting paid
six figures if it's a bank maybe more if
it's
you know certain certain tech firms and
you look up you're like oh my gosh like
what's going on am i missing out because
i'm here in new orleans working for
you know a certain amount of money it's
a very difficult landscape
um you know venture for america had a
degree of
of success but also i realized the
enormity of the problem there was a
tweet during the middle of the pandemic
where some guy was like
um he was an employee at google and then
had pretended to quit and got a job at
facebook and then was being paid by both
and because they're working from home
valley episode
it's like out of silicon valley or
office space and you think this is an
absolute [ __ ] joke and meanwhile you
know
the earth is burning to the ground you
know you know we can't
we can't even figure out how to like uh
do anything except distribute burritos
by cars to people i mean it's kind of
[Music]
crazy
i am a dad and
i am always getting invited to dad
things
and then you're like what kind of prezi
does this kid want and you have no clue
what that other
that other families kid want no it's
true you're like i have no idea what
your kid likes
uh and then you just take a guess and
you're just like all right i guess that
you know
as long as i i fulfilled my social
obligations were okay
but you know what the kids actually
would love they would love
a subscription book club that sends five
beautiful children's books
to the family every month and picked by
experts
tell me that all of the parents you know
would not love you for that
know what i mean like if they're
struggling with their kids and as a
parent i'll tell you like
you're always just trying to stay one
step ahead of um
you know whatever your kids uh wants and
needs are if you could set it and forget
it where you just get sent
five kids books that are curated and
appropriate
that's a game changer for parents and
this makes a phenomenal gift
gift subscriptions are available for 1 3
6 or 12 months of books
so you could go the whole year and being
like i'm gonna get you 12
gift boxes of books you probably need to
be related to that person
or you could give them like one or three
months if you know it's not that big a
deal to you
so this is the gift that's going to
knock it out of the park for all the
parents
in your life go to literati.com
yang for 25 off your first two orders
and pick your kids book club gift today
no one else has kids book clubs like
this
only at literary.com yang can you get 25
off your first two orders and receive
five kids books curated by experts
delivered to your door or your friend's
door
every month that's literati.com yang
make someone's holiday season actually
like just be the gift that keeps on
giving this year
[Applause]
i want to dig into the example you just
used about
for example trying to make people's home
zero remission and i was a judge at a
of a clean tech competition recently and
the winner
was this very simple product that was
essentially a film you put over windows
that make them
retain heat and energy better and one of
the wonderful things about this product
was that you don't need to be
that high skilled to install on windows
i mean it's essentially a window
treatment
so to me the problem
is that like what percentage of american
homes right now have this
with this uh enviro-friendly window
treatment
you know virtually zero uh and
if you were to go to folks right now and
say hey would you like this window
treatment if it will pay
for itself within 18 months like
including installation
most americans would say sure but right
now there's not like um
there's not a mechanism to drive
widespread adoption
like of that product uh and that's like
to me a very simple
straightforward example um now the the
the solar panels that could help make
the um
the houses zero emission let's say would
be like an order of magnitude more
difficult than this window treatment i'm
describing
so the problem right now to me is that
like there are
market failures in the talent level
which i agree is uh
really really hurting us in a massive
way it's hurting us culturally
economically
like in innovation and then
there are inefficiencies in the market
where you can see opportunities where
folks should be
installing this window treatment or or
solar panels and it could be that maybe
the solar panels aren't ready for prime
time
and you need to innovate to try and get
them to a point where you know they're
more cost effective this window
treatment is definitely cost effective
now
you know it's like again like the the
simplest thing in the world um
but uh they they're just a startup
they've got
not that much money and so they're
looking around for ways to try and
get folks excited about their product
you know like
establish some kind of brand and track
record
and i feel like there are a host of
companies that are like
that that window treatment company where
they've got something they've got
something they've got something real
uh it would make a positive impact it
doesn't get widespread adoption they're
not made of money
uh to make it happen and the value golf
for someone
isn't so vast that and i'll use myself
as an example like i judge this
cleantech competition i love that
product i was like that should win
and then did i turn around and like get
those you know with a window treatment
done in my own
home like you know like i have not yet
and i apologize
but that but that's like the example is
like you know i was like staring right
at it
um and it would save me money eventually
but like it wasn't enough to impel me to
act
um again this maybe says something
negative about me and i'm sorry audience
that i didn't do this um so so that to
me is like uh is an example of like kind
of the the problems that we're we're
facing where
even if you have something that um
could help right now our market is not
properly
uh rewarding adoption um and it would
reward adoption
of some other things that probably
aren't going to be as positive
yeah we are um we are in this really
important moment in time where
um folks will have to make some really
important decisions about what their
priorities are
um look i think that one of the things
that you
did um and this is going to be and i've
and i've
you know had a reasonably good track
record of not necessarily being
contrarian but generally getting it
right
so i'm just going to put something out
there which is that you know there was a
lot of talk
in the democratic presidential
nomination process
about the progressive left and
there was this interesting thing which
is that you were this
kind of like weird character that kind
of just emerged
which was like smart and like normal
and plain spoken and like all these sort
of like
other smart normal plain spoken people
were like yeah i like
math i like you know things that make
sense i like sentences when he says
something
um and uh and i think that um
there is something that's happening
which is hard to appreciate which is
that
you know progressivism i think is a
doomed experiment
it's the first initial reaction of an
extremely frustrated class of people
but i think what it gets replaced with
is pragmatism
and i think what's interesting that the
most indelible thing about the 2020
election process will be that
you probably created um
you showed product market fit for
pragmatism
and i think that joe biden took
advantage of pragmatism
and he monetized it um and i don't think
there's anything to be ashamed of
because
that happens a lot in technology
products that wins you know some guy
innovates and the other guy monetizes
and kind of closes the deal
um but it is the winning strategy
and um back to this sort of like film
company why i think this
is important is that there are all kinds
of technologies that right now
are not managed pragmatically now i
don't know about this thing but
if this thing is wrapped in some dude
with a hipster beard and hemp pants he
can go [ __ ] himself because it's not
gonna work
right he needs to be pragmatic it's like
what the hell do these films cost how do
i get them to the house how does
somebody come and install them
how do you give me an app that shows me
how much money i'm saving how do i make
sure i don't look like an idiot for
doing it especially if the film is ugly
if he can pragmatically figure it out
and separate
all the emotional you know handwriting
around climate change
that company will win and uh i think
that we are going to get faced with a
whole suite of decisions like that
over the next five or ten years as
consumers that we can make at the
political level
at the product level at the technology
level do you want pragmatism
and in a world where you decide yes
we'll have a lot of solutions and a
world where
you want to wrap yourself around a flag
of you know identity politics and all
this other [ __ ]
then we're just going to stay where we
are well to me the issue with that
uh the that window treatment company you
know it's related to
what's happened with solar and what
happened with
electric cars and other things i think
at some point the government the public
sector has to say you know what
we really want solar energy to grow
even though right now it's not cost
competitive with
uh with fossil fuels we're gonna help
make it happen like i feel like
something like that has to happen with a
window treatment where it's like you
know what
like we can't get customers to get that
excited about this just yet because
they're just kind of shrugging and like
you know letting heat escape through
their windows
but we want to create jobs because there
are over 10 million americans who are
out of jobs
and we think it would be great for homes
to have this window like so this is the
this is what compelled me to eventually
run for president i certainly appreciate
your characterizing me as like the
um out of nowhere
plain spoken like sets talking figure
that makes you very happy
and this is what i'm i'm trying to
connect with you on or figure out where
we diverge
is like at some point i said okay of
like the biggest hairiest
problems you're going to need the public
sector to get it [ __ ] together
or we're [ __ ] was like eventually
where i landed
and then and then the public sector is
not exactly
like a paragon of like efficiency or
rationality or the rest of it
but i just did not see a way for us to
solve some of the biggest hairiest
problems
without the public sector saying you
know what i think it might be a good
idea to get this window treatment guys
i'll give you two examples where the
public markets or sorry
the public sector is actually getting
their [ __ ] together
so the the first is in climate change
and the single biggest boon
to climate change is the fact that we
have
all of these really complicated politics
in america
foreign policy related to the middle
east and to russia
and the most important thing that i
think
is happening is the following dots are
being connected
the faster that america basically puts
the need to burn fossil fuels
out of business the faster that saudi
arabia
all of the middle east and all of russia
will have to monetize their oil because
if the future price is zero then you're
gonna pull all the oil out of the earth
today to try to get whatever you can for
it even if it's a dollar a dollar today
is worth
better more than zero tomorrow and in
that
a couple of things happen the middle
east actually has one incredible asset
going for it in a world of climate
change
that is sunlight it has an enormous
amount of sunlight in fact
you know you may not know this uh maybe
you do but you know the country that is
the single most advantaged country in a
world of photovoltaics
um and in a world of solar is uh
uh armenia i did not know that
it's like the sunniest saudi arabia yeah
but but the point is that um
all of that will allow us to basically
completely refactor geopolitics so
you know the middle east will be okay
there's going to be less fundamentalism
there's
no because there's just going to be no
money to fund it so it doesn't matter
who you are but you'll be like hey guys
i want to raise my series b for isis and
people are like no
you know we did the seed round it didn't
kind of work we did the series a we hate
it we're done
um and then the countries that it really
really you know puts me on the eight
ball is russia
because they don't necessarily have the
mechanisms to move off of fossil fuels
so for example like you know our foreign
policy posture
will actually drive climate adoption
more than people realize
but in that what i think will happen is
like basically russia gets put into a
corner even more that they are now
the middle east then becomes an element
where imagine they
have all of this sunlight the biggest
thing that we haven't yet figured out
andrew in technology
in climate technology is how to actually
take the sun
and use it to heat water and create
steam at above 1500 degrees centigrade
now you may say well what the [ __ ] what
are you talking about
that is the most basic building block of
any single factory
because the minute and right now the
only way that we get steam to be super
super hot and to you know use it to melt
steel and make aluminum and
stamp out you know whatever crap we buy
from china
it takes a furnace and it takes an
enormous amount of fossil fuels
if all of a sudden you figure out how to
use the sunlight what america can do
again with our foreign policy is we can
fund
an entire factory build out all
throughout the middle east and you know
who it hurts
china now think of the two countries
we've been told for the
in every administration who is literally
an enormous pain in our ass
china and russia and climate change
basically nullifies both of them
and on top of that you have this
enormous demographic bubble in china
where you know in the next 50 years
um they're going to have half as many
people because everybody's basically
dying and the birth rate is negative
so so we're set up in a place where like
the biden administration can basically
deal the death blow
from a foreign policy perspective
because we don't need to
you know hack china or russia we don't
need to invade folks we don't need to
arm
you know countries against them none of
that needs to happen all we need to do
is become carbon neutral because the
minute that we do that
then i think you know what you have is
russia in a really precarious position
financially
and the middle east that probably
becomes the next manufacturing mecca for
the world
which then puts chinese gdp
superiority in massive risk
so these are all these sort of
interconnected things that i try to
think about a lot but um
this is why i'm spending so much time in
climate change because not only will you
create
great products will the air be more
breathable will kids be able to study
easier
you know will the the sea stop you know
sea level stop rising
but you fix all the geopolitical [ __ ]
that we've been in for the last 20 years
it's month 18 of the quarantine it's not
quite month 18 but it sure feels like
it uh and one of the things that's
harder and harder for all of us
is to eat healthy to take care of
yourself uh to feel good about yourself
day to day
if you don't take care of yourself then
nothing else works and one way you can
take care of yourself
is by putting good stuff in your body
athletic greens is a product
where they've put together 75 vitamins
minerals whole food
sourced ingredients into one mixture you
put it in water
you drink it and then your body feels
energized
all day athletic greens is really the
the name for this thing because
there's a lot of good stuff going into
your body that you know you need
you're not going to get unless you're
like consuming tons of salads and
vegetation i can't speak highly enough
about the fact that this stuff
really does feel like you're treating
your body better and your body rewards
you for it
so if this sounds like something that
would help you get through
your weeks go to athleticgreens.comyang
and get a free year supply of vitamin d
and travel packs in addition uh to your
order
that's athletic greens.com yang get more
athletic
become greener
[Applause]
one thing i love talking to folks like
you about is what you see
coming down the pike because your job is
essentially to both tell and build the
future
um so of the things that you're seeing
that you're excited about one it sounds
like
you're very optimistic that we'll be
able to uh
advance cures for various diseases i
mean that like that that would obviously
be
uh incredibly good news for millions of
americans and a lot of other folks it
sounds like you're optimistic
about um moving towards being
zero emission or carbon neutral uh
in the days to come so like what are you
seeing that you're super
pumped about i also want to call out
something that you're doing when i saw
that you're trying to train
investment managers in a way that it
sounds a validly
pro-social you're just like hey let's
like find a way to train folks
at scale that's outside of like the
traditional bounds you don't need to go
get some expensive degree and the rest
of it you're gonna it's not it sounded
to me like you're gonna find people with
like unconventional backgrounds
um so i i you know want to congratulate
you on that
um so what are you seeing that or doing
that you're excited about right now that
will help someone visualize what the
future could be like in the next number
of years
the way that i would put it is i think
that if i had to be somewhat
cynical about my career trajectory the
first
25 years has been you know by all
measures successful
but success has come by husbanding
information
right i had a knowledge edge and we
didn't necessarily share that knowledge
widely you know i knew things that other
people didn't
know i think for the next 50 years of my
career what i would like to do
is break down those barriers and share
all the knowledge that i've accumulated
like google makes all the information
available at your fingertips but
information and knowledge as you know
andrew are two totally different things
um but i want to share my knowledge and
so i'll give you three areas that i
think are going to get revolutionized
and i would love to be a part of it
the pandemic has really shown to me that
our education infrastructure is totally
broken
i have kids so
so watching them uh struggle with online
school has been
miserable you know and and we all talk
about online schools
um and i'm like online school better
than nothing
but not great you know so i went looking
for data points
on how kids are learning and the data
points i found were that
that online learning is 30 to 70 percent
as effective
as in person school so i just wanted to
throw that that
data point in there before you continue
well no so to your point like
i think what the pandemic did was
behaviorally show that kids
um can adapt and actually
at least learn something in a remote
environment
and that they can learn where you know
they are
essentially virtual okay i think the
reason why that's important is that a
whole bunch of services have also
cropped up
that allow you to find the best grade 5
math teacher
the best grade 6 algebra teacher the
best grade 7 history teacher
the the best grade 11 drama teacher and
i think in the 21st century especially
in america
it stands to reason that we should be
able to give
these incredible teachers we should pay
them like athletes they should get paid
more like lebron and jonas
you know steph curry these guys should
be making 30 40 50 million bucks a year
and they should be teaching all american
grade five great sixth grade seven grade
usuals
and when you're in school you should be
consuming this video content
with incredible local teachers that help
supplement and reinforce
what these best-in-class folks teach us
you know that's just like a thing where
it's like
let's make sure again we even the
starting lines
right that we're not husbanding
knowledge that it's not the kid that's
in [ __ ] larchmont
that gets a better occasion than the kid
in the bronx that's not fair
right because that kid in the bronx
could be the next steve jobs
and we're not going to get a chance to
find out because that kid's teacher is
just not as good as the kids teachers in
rye and larchmont
and um you know greenwich connecticut
and so this is something technology can
fix we can even
the starting line not even the finish
line but even the starting line that
seemed to me
that seems to me like a really
reasonable and humane and
good thing to do so that's something in
education that i see coming down the
pipe
um in financial technology in fintech
one of the most important things that we
can do one of the most important things
that i can do
is make the knowledge i know about how
to make money
widely consumable train many other
people
in the lessons that i've learned so that
they can make money
for normal ordinary folks and this is a
very simple way to
close the inequality gap profit has a
saying
which is that the way you make money is
not timing the market it's
time in the market and so
you know my emerging managers program i
had a thousand people apply
i'm gonna teach thousands and thousands
of people what i know
i'm not saying that what i know is
special and will always be unique but
for right now what i know is how to make
billions and billions of dollars a year
and so let them make billions and
billions of dollars for other people
that would be amazing um and then a
third example
is that you know i've been working with
a team these are folks that i
partnered with out of google in a
startup that's been building
um a chip for human learning
and machine learning and again this is
important because i think we are
bumping up against the laws of physics
and i think that we're almost at a
position to bend these laws of physics
in a way
where we can create so much computing
resources available
and if you combine that with some of
these things that i spoke about earlier
like what google is doing with
protein simulations um
we're going to solve all human disease
um
and you know it's not going to cost that
much money 5 billion 10 billion dollars
like not a big deal
you know i can fund it zuck it funded
gates could fund it who cares and
so one of us should do it um and so i
think those are three examples of areas
that i'm
pretty um addicted to beyond climate
change i would say climate is my first
one to be completely honest with you
andrew it's kind of become an obsessive
sure
it drives everything else i mean heck
plus you live in california and
literally like the
countryside's a blaze you have no idea
like in september
um the sky was orange and it looked like
it was out of a
a movie where like aliens were invading
i've never felt more
insecure since i moved to the united
states i mean
i had my my next most moment of
insecurity was
when you know trump won the election i
thought i was going to get kicked out
and sent to some internment camp i
really did uh and then the second most
insecure moment i ever had was looking
at the forest fires in california
when i was here no i mean you were
obviously focused on climate change well
before the sky turned orange but the sky
turning orange i'm sure
made you feel like you were making the
right choices you're like that goodness
i'm working on this
uh that there was like a piece of it too
i was trying to figure out what you
could do to
try and prevent the forest fires and it
turns out that we properly managed
something like two percent of the
nation's forest
the forest that was burning in
california as a national forest like the
state of california doesn't even really
have jurisdiction over it
and so i looked at the u.s forest
service's budget
and the u.s forest services budget
probably shocking to no one here
has not changed that much in the last
number of years even as you can tell the
forest has been drying and turning into
more of a tinder box
because you know i looked at what was
going on in california and i thought
this is tragic and terrible
and it would be incredibly destructive
for any form of confidence
trees are an incredible um carbon sink
as you know
if you look across the world the united
states is probably the third or fourth
best place to grow trees
um you know the amazon being the best
and then indonesia colombia there's
there's a handful of places that are
incredible
and within the united states it's
actually north carolina mississippi
that corridor which is the best if you
just look at vegetation and whatnot
um so we got really interested to your
point i got interested in this too and i
was like what could we do in
reforestation and so we started a
project where you know we're buying
i can't remember the exact number so
this is going to sound a little aloof
but
10 000 or 100 000 acres and we have
these drones
that map the burnt down forest
yeah and the drones have guns and it
does
it shoots saplings into the ground and
so it's kind of like a whole star wars
thing where like these drones just
you know come up over the hill and then
they run over all this land
and just start freaking planting trees
from the sky like i've seen this stuff
and it was it's like the coolest thing
in the world
so i'm going to run this by you uh
chemaf because i was again i was trying
to figure out okay how can you help with
this forest management
um the obvious thing to do would be to
like hire uh tens of thousands of park
rangers to
burn off uh you know the the brush and
actually try and manage the forest in
like a
sensible way there are some politics
around that but at this point i
feel like it's obvious but then i was
imagining just like you had the drones
fly over and just freaking start like
planting trees
by the thousands and these acres of land
like i was trying to imagine okay
could you have a set of drones that are
hovering
over this forest along with heat sensors
and then whenever like a fire started
going up
then the the drones actually can like
pick up on it being like hey guys fyi
there's a brush fire in sector
you know like a h4 andrew it's a great
[ __ ] idea
this is what i mean like look there's
there's and here's by the way can i just
say the other thing
the other thing is that we've
bastardized entrepreneurship in america
where people think that starting a
company needs to mean you become a
you know centi billionaire otherwise
you've failed and
that's just not true okay you don't want
to be
as dysfunctional as it takes to make
that much money
just let me just tell you being up close
and personal to it
what i will tell you is that there's
enormous respect that you should have
for yourself and even building a company
where you can have
eight nine ten employees all of you can
have families and homes and
you know support your community and you
send your kids to college and you have
some savings that's amazing too
so so you should go and somebody should
go and start this business that does
that
you know heat sensing with drones sells
that service back to
local state and federal authorities
makes a couple million dollars a year in
their company
has 15 or 20 people employed everybody
can make a very good living wage
that is success i can i could not agree
more
you know one of the things that breaks
my heart right now is all of the small
business owners are going bust
because their business is drying up
because of the pandemic and
if you have even a restaurant or bar or
food truck i mean you're employing like
four or five people
or in some cases restaurants would be
dozens um hundreds of people uh
like that is success i agree with you i
mean i ran a small private company
myself
i had nowhere near the level of
commercial success as
um you know you or some of the people
you know
but i felt very very um proud
andrew let's be honest more people look
up to you than look up to those folks
and the reason again is because there's
a humanity and an authenticity
in just trying to do good by people and
look you can get really cutthroat and
all of a sudden make all the money quote
unquote
it's not a path to happiness
you know and uh i've learned the hard
way because i've fallen for this trap
many times there's been a bunch of times
at the fork in the road where i've said
okay it's not enough and it's like what
the [ __ ] do you mean it's not enough
it is enough it's all enough it's like
now the real solution
to your happiness is about being
fulfilled and all of these other things
that don't come from making money
and it comes from employing people and
knowing that they have good lives
and you know i i've started to explore
for example a different program
to try to instigate some change in
uh student debt it's called income
sharing agreements right where
you pay people to go to college or to a
trade school and you get a share of
their income
above a certain threshold right um and
then they pay you back
and then they're never in debt and you
know you kind of if
it works at the scale of a billion
dollars it does kind of really put
student lending on its heels but what is
that that's an effort to sort of like
say
yeah could you make a ton more money
doing something else possibly
but will this make you know millions of
people's lives
meaningfully better even if you
basically break even and then some
yeah that's better um
so i think it's good to have examples of
folks like you basically reminding
people that like
this this kind of like crazy obsession
with wealth that we have in america
is really not what it was ever and it
was not what it was all about
you know jamaat like there's a regular
joke around um
my family and the yang gang um that i
would get described as a billionaire
periodically
uh and we had a good laugh because my
wife would be like well it's news to me
because it's like living like a pretty
normal life
um and you know i i think that your
experience is really
fascinating on this level too because
you know you reached a level of uh
business success that most people
uh can only only dream of but i have
friends
who um also like struggle with
uh i mean the heck the most like the
most glaring example from
a recent history is like the tragic
story of tony shea who i'm sure you knew
because
you know that like our circles are not
that big um did you know tony
uh i knew him sort of arms arms length
i've met him three or four times but i
didn't really know him that well
so tony obviously i mean world famous
entrepreneur worth hundreds of millions
of dollars
uh and had a void that you know is
difficult to fill and then when the
coronavirus shut down
your ability to socialize in various
ways then you know like tragedy followed
thereafter
i mean the the human condition is
inescapable
it's universal it's everywhere uh i
certainly feel
very fortunate that i went down a path
where i was trying to do
good stuff and help people and my wife
is a rock star on this so like i
i ran a private company it gets bought
for like a little bit of money 2009 and
then i go
kind of wholesome do-goodery uh
non-profit guy
with the thought process being like look
i made enough money so i can like
work for essentially for free for like a
period of
and i had timed it for myself i said i
can work and not just not worry about
money for five years
and at the end of that like hopefully i
will have done something positive with
this nonprofit
and then have it then six and a half
years later i was like okay the problems
i was trying to tackle are so much
bigger than anything i could have
imagined
um like the only thing i could think of
that would actually give me a real
chance of solving the problem
uh was run for president which was also
by the way economically uh highly
impractical
but but then thanks to like folks who
actually started to
uh support me and believe in me like you
know the campaign worked out at a
particular level
um and now i literally like i wake up
and just trying to find ways to help
people and like do positive things
um and it's really exciting um
and like it goes back to what you were
talking about before where you have
these five mega corps you'll just
freaking
you know drop six and seven figures on
on young people and say like you know
your highest use is hanging out
uh here in the mothership um
and the intellectual lobotomization of
america my
my turn or phrase for it jamal back when
i was young and this is not a knock i'm
sorry i'm sorry
um but i was a corporate attorney for
five months um and uh
it was a fine firm and they were very
good to me um but i
i said at the time that this place is
like a temple to the squandering of
human potential
because it had like a lot of really
bright people but we were
handling uh the minutiae of uh corporate
transaction documents
and i was like this cannot be the
highest use of this
group of people because you know there's
some very very talented people on these
walls uh and then i
made the decision to go you know start a
business which flopped and then like i
had
some real real struggles in my 20s
because
i was making less money than everyone i
knew like you know i'd have all these
bad dates because like i would go out
and like
you know i'd be self-conscious about um
money or like you know buying like you
know
like you know uh like a certain type of
meal or like taking with someone to a
certain sort of place
uh so i went through like a real
journey that way um that ended up making
it so that
my standards for myself materially were
like just not that high
and i also got lucky i married a woman
who's um like
you know cool with her uh husband
uh not maximizing my economic
opportunities at every turn
um but the the thing that you know i
tried to do with venture for america and
the thing i'm still
sort of pushing on it is really trying
to unlock
folks from um
the the paths that our market will kind
of drive them towards
uh and and one thing i think excites so
many people about you
is that people can sense that you're
driven by something bigger
than maximizing your bank account yeah i
am i'm driven by um
really trying to figure out who i am and
just to have more happy days than
unhappy days
and i know that sounds so stupid and
trite and like some people can say well
yeah you're in a position to do that and
it's like no i learned that
i was chasing other people's definitions
of success for so long
and that's what was making me so unhappy
and so that's why things were never
enough
because it was somebody else's
definition of what should have made me
happy and so when i got it
i wasn't happy yeah i mean i was happy
for a second or whatever
you know get a job get a promotion buy a
car buy a better car
buy a house and now my life is
um really really simple like i mean i
look forward to like
you know and and as a result my ego's
gotten a lot less and so like
you know a simple example um i do
pilates
dude that's awesome i do pilates now why
you know in my 20s and 30s i was i got
to go work out i'm working out
and i was in constant [ __ ] pain and
then i realized it just doesn't matter
what i look like
it matters how i feel and pilates twice
a week makes me go to sleep andrew would
wake up and i don't know if you see this
in your 40s but
it makes me wake up pain-free wow
it makes me so happy like more than
anything else in the world when i wake
up and my back isn't feeling like it's
wretched and
my knees and whatever i'm really happy i
can start the day
with less um with less you know kind of
like
mental stress right that's a really
simple thing
um and so i've learned over time that
i've
built pretty basically and you know
spending time with my kids and
all of these things are just not things
that i knew how to think about because
other people's definitions were caught
up in
a lot of superficiality and that's where
we all lose our way
um and so you know if i can work on
projects that are inspiring
that's pretty cool if i can make
decisions that's cool
i also just want to be able to say
things even if they're not cool to some
folks
because that's another thing that i
think really prevents people from being
happy right now i i do think that
there's just um everybody's so pent up
they're ready to judge they're ready to
cancel folks they're ready to just kind
of like wipe them off as
and they're ready to be judgmental and
um again another
key feature of pragmatism i think is you
know that everybody's got something
useful to do and to say
and you find a way of just forgiving you
know the bursts that people may regret
in their youth or otherwise for example
you know i had this thing uh last week
where uh i've i've been
saying pretty vociferously we are headed
for a biological patriarch in america a
patriot act in america
we there it is inconceivable that if
you're working at a company or if you're
part of a union or if you're going to
get on a plane
that you're not going to want to have
some insurance about the people around
you having been vaccinated like that
ship
in my opinion is [ __ ] sailed and so
like all the anti-vaxxers will have to
have
a market clearing price to pay for a
choice of not vaccinating themselves
because now that we have these kinds of
communicable diseases this is the
beginning not the end
of airborne diseases like coronavirus
covet 19 will
will be followed by covet 20 and covet
21 and covet 22 and covet 35
and these will be pernicious diseases
and so there will be
a mandate to vaccinate and i know that
that pisses off a lot of people but so
be it
and i put this out on twitter and i said
maybe folks that get vaccinated should
wear a pin or a mask
and people equated it to the holocaust
and i was like holy [ __ ] that is
super judgmental and really really like
wow that is that is an intense reaction
so there's no way to have a debate you
know you can't have a conversation about
these things and what i try to tell
people is like well
if you don't want to mask guess what the
government's going to mandate an app and
are you going to be happier or sadder
when now all of a sudden there's a
central repository that china and russia
are trying to hack
that is all of our vaccination histories
online i've got a quick question on this
point
if i get vaccinated uh and you're not
vaccinated
like that's your problem not mine right
like as long as i'm vaccinated
at least i'm gonna get rid of because
like because
my plan is to get vaccinated you know
very publicly um
and then at that point um if someone
around me does not get vaccinated like
they're in trouble but i'm not in
trouble
is my understanding i don't know if
that's right i'm just asking a question
hypothetically uh
because um like i feel like the folks
who are going to suffer from
non-compliance
are the people who don't get vaccinated
i think it's tbd um and the reason i say
tbd is i think that we need to see
you know typical vaccines the the
the you know phase three testing
protocols take
years you know we've accelerated things
and we've we've truncated the entire
process phase one to phase three in nine
months
and so you know we have early efficacy
data we have early transmission data we
have early
that's true if it's 95 and then everyone
around you is like non-vaccinated and
contagious then it could
like that five percent's a problem
that's true what if the half-life of
this thing is nine months or
18 months what if you need to get
vaccinated three or four times
what if only 35 percent of the
population get vaccinated even at 95
efficacy you still have an are not
greater than one and so you have a
disease that's that's causing
a tremendous burden that could be
shutting down businesses and economies
and
i don't know that's right so my point my
point in all of this in bringing up this
example is just back to the other thing
which is like
i think part of being happy is being
able to say things and not being
attacked
and not being judged and not being
cancelled and
being able to find a pragmatic way of
talking about ideas one of the
principles that i want to stand for
is grace and uh
forgiveness not forgiveness even because
a lot of this shit's not even wrong it's
more like grace and understanding or
grace and humanity
and one of the things i know as a like a
now a public figure
if you were to take a minute of my worst
moments i would seem like a raging
[ __ ]
no doubt about it and and so you know
like
we're holding um everyone to a standard
that
like none of us could satisfy if you
took us at our worst um
and there are times when someone just
gets videotaped at their worst
like you know in public like they're
like you know a total [ __ ] to
someone in public and then like their
their life gets ruined
um you know and obviously like you know
i prefer that maybe they hadn't done
whatever the
the heck they did but um but again if
someone had a camera on me in my worst
60 seconds
like uh i would seem like a terrible
human and i just think that's true of
every single one of us
um and if you're going to have a
discussion
uh it's one of the reasons why and i
think people know this about me it's
like i i sit down and have conversations
with people
that you know like i disagree with on
like various things political or
otherwise
um and i just think it's ridiculous that
like somehow i'm supposed
to be like mindful of the fact that
someone might disagree with me on some
level it's like
like you know it'd be surprising if they
didn't disagree with me on some level
because we're both different human
beings anyway just wanted to
echo what you're suggesting i think that
we all
are trying our best and yes i think it's
when we forget that that we just act
like raging [ __ ] but we are
all honestly trying our best every day
and if you
if you keep it in mind it's amazing um
you know how much empathy you can have
for other people i don't think that that
was
a particular skill of mine i had a real
chip on my shoulder which was like
i had a tough life so you know f this f
that f the other person this person had
a cushy life this person was rich
you know and i just realized no we are
we're all trying our best
and um you know that's really helped me
a lot
um it's it's not to say that people give
that
back to me but
at least i can give it to other people
well well i i hope you receive more of
it uh jamaa
and you know pilates so many people
swear by it like it seems like it makes
your connective tissue
um like stronger and healthier in a way
i feel like everyone would benefit from
because we're about the same age i'm 45
you're 44. um
and there there is like an adaptation
that occurs like around this age where
like the [ __ ] you did when you were a
young man like just does not work as
well
i can drink once or twice a week now you
know what i mean like if i
if i get even buzzed i don't sleep well
i wake up the next day i feel like
complete [ __ ] it's just not what it was
like 20s and 30s
i could rage wake up go and do whatever
you know
it's just not it's just not what it is
and it's so i have to reframe my
expectations and
find what really makes me happy yes and
find new ways to
to be excited and fulfilled um because i
like diminishing returns to some of the
things that we did when we were younger
and then you kind of find the new things
with expanding returns
certainly for me kids are a big part of
that you know like and there are times
when i'm playing with my kids
um where frankly like work creeps in and
i'm like oh [ __ ] i need to get back to
this person but then i'm just like you
know if i can't enjoy this time with my
kids i'm sunk
you know so then like you you have to
say to yourself like this is
the purpose you know like like you know
i don't um
like i i shouldn't be like you know
trying to abbreviate this time i should
be trying to
uh elongate it the two best memories of
the last month
that i have were one when we all decided
me and my kids
have four kids that we wanted to watch
tenet and we pre-ordered it
and dude well yeah so i
so it got released two days ago so i
know this because we would check it is
it released yet is it released yet and i
mean
and so we've been building this thing up
now 10 it could be the worst [ __ ]
movie alive it won't matter because
we are all so pent up my myself my
partner
my kids and then the second is we
watched and if you've never watched it i
would tell your audience to do it too
we all on a saturday binge watched never
have i ever
which is uh a netflix comedy that's been
that's executive produced by mindy
kaling from the office
it is so [ __ ] brilliant and uh
these are the two moments of the
pandemic that i remember the most over
the last two months
jumping screaming laughing anyways
small things can make a big difference
in people's lives it allows you to find
more empathy for others i think
okay never have i ever done for me and
my audience the question is like have
you seen tennant and is it awesome
uh no we're watching it tomorrow night
this is a problem my kids
you know in the middle of the pandemic
like their only social interaction
is through um roblox or
you know fortnite because they can talk
to their friends in a non-school setting
and so
you know i give them the choice i'm like
you can have you know
60 minutes of game time or a two-hour
movie like we'll take the game time
and then like but then i'm like but then
you got to read and do the dishes and
like plow the driveway they're like
that's fine
so we negotiated thursday so i get to
watch it tomorrow with them so i can't
wait
well well i hope it's awesome um uh
congratulations to you for the work
you're doing to help build a future
that's
habitable and healthy and everything
else you're doing uh
there are not many people like you who
are trying to solve
human problems that are not being
uh frankly rewarded by the market at the
same
pace or level um and so i i was excited
to sit down with you i'm excited to see
what you do next i'm excited to see the
future you help us
uh get through appreciate the heck out
of your time you're you're a real
inspiration and i'll tell you why
also just growing up as an immigrant
person to see
somebody who kind of takes the world
stage the way you did just
personally for me i'm sure you've heard
that a lot from folks but it's inspiring
to see somebody just go for it
and i just want to thank you because it
gives
my kid my children are half south asian
half asian
and so you know there's a context where
like you know my kids see
you know an older version of themselves
on a debate stage
it's really [ __ ] amazing so i just
want to say thanks for inspiring a lot
of people
including myself i really appreciate it
all the best to your kids
uh tell them i'll do better next time
thanks andrew thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you